hey youtubers it's Charlie thank you
everybody there's many questions on my
Robb Stark video a lot of questions
about what's going on with as well like
what the stark line of succession might
be especially what's going on with Sansa
and the Bolton's right now there will be
some interesting questions for the show
dancer when it comes back because
technically Ramsay Bolton did consummate
the marriage with Sansa and she's on the
run with reek right now until someone
with a more legitimate claim comes along
they by rights do hold the north not
that you'd be able to convince the
actual citizens of the north of that
that kind of reminds me when Joffrey
almost got ripped limb from limb by the
mob and Kings Landing just because you
have legal claim to something does not
mean the citizens will support it
especially if you're super unpopular
which is kind of what the Bolton's are
right now in the north lot of questions
though here we go careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen all the way through
season five yet on the TV show so here
we go John shark asks will this letter
somehow provide protection for Sansa who
is now on the run if the northern Lords
recognized Jon Snow's that air Sansa but
in a way inherit protection from the
Bolton's right well I don't think that
Sansa would would need any kind of
official letter or anything to provide
any cut protection and and just for
those he's talking about the will Robb
Stark's both like the letters that he
sent out no I think that she'd be fine
going to any of the other northern Lords
I don't want to say unanimously like
every single person from every house in
the North completely one hundred percent
House Stark over house Bolton there are
over forty five houses in the north so
they're probably at least like one or
two to be too afraid to help her but for
the most part if she were to say to go
to like the Glovers in Deepwood Motte or
go to the last hearth and try and stay
with the embers they would they would
totally help her no matter what I think
of that situation it'd actually be reek
that would be in trouble because most of
the greater lords would probably know
what he looks like and know what he did
the thing is is like the north is a big
place so there might be some people in
some places that have never seen Sansa
Stark before but for the most part like
the greater houses have all probably
seen her at some point next question
Salem asks if Jon Snow lives in Stannis
is dead do you think that John is Azure
a high the way I'd like to think of it I
don't know which interpretation this
show is actually going to go with but I
think of azor Ahai as being more of a
metaphor like not an actual person just
a title that gets given to someone at
any
given time I do think he's going to be
resurrected and by default that will
make him a very special person in the
narrative but I don't know that that
will bestow extra powers on top of him
like I think the fact that he holds a
Valyrian blade like if Melisandre were
to say like light it on fire in it
glowed just like Stannis's blade did
whenever she lit it on fire then you
could call him as or high and I don't
think any of the other characters like
anywhere in the world would challenge
that they would just be like oh ok so we
heard this story of him being
resurrected by the Lord of Light he has
a flaming blade he must be this mythical
figure it's totally ok to be skeptical
about that just because it seems like
the obvious choice like he and denier
seemed like the obvious choice to be
this mythical figure just because it
seems like there's been so many clues
that support that evidence I know
everyone is kind of wondering if it's
going to be some unexpected person
that'll be a Zorua hi I think the title
is exactly that just a title that can be
given to anyone at any given time the
real key is getting everyone to believe
it and it's a lot easier to do that when
you see someone get resurrected next
question Gallifreyan gamer asks when do
you think that the surviving start
children like Sansa and Arya will
reunite and in what circumstance I think
bran will forever be the three-eyed
Raven but surely the stark girls will
see each other again well I'm actually
I'm kind of hoping that they don't meet
up I do hope that they learned that each
other is alive but I don't want them to
like have a really maudlin like hug it
out moment that's more of like a cynical
view but is I feel like it would be a
little over the top if like everybody
got their hearts wish like it turned
into fan fiction you could argue that
it's already moved into fan fiction
territory it just I feel it be a little
bit more believable for Aria to learn
that stance is still alive and feel some
measure of relief and then just kind of
like continue on with her life somewhere
else you know wandering around the earth
being a faceless person and Sansa kind
of did the same thing where she lives
out the rest of her life knowing that
her sister was alive you know but not
getting to see her it'd be like happy
and sad at the same time next question
Carlo asks how things would have been if
the Knights of the Vale had united with
the north once again are you assume
you're talking about Stannis Stannis's
army I do think that they'll be an
alliance with the veil but I just I
think it'll be somebody else from the
north that's putting an army together it
just it makes sense if they're loyal to
your house and they have this giant
force and they hate the people that are
the occupying Winterfell this is really
where Littlefinger is probably gonna
shine I mean it hopefully like his
storyline kind of seemed to trickle off
at the end of last season his whole
thing is that he's trying to hold the
veil like he's trying to keep control of
the veil well at the same time playing
the Bolton's in the crown against each
other and trying to secure the loyalty
of the Tyrells i should add he's
definitely trying to play the Tyrells
against the crown but the queen of
thorns is just like a little bit smarter
than everyone else so she is very aware
that he is trying to do that but long
answer done short you will definitely
get to see Knights of the Vale fighting
against Bolton's eventually next
question so I don't want to mispronounce
your name but you had a really good
question yes about Benjen stark how did
Benjen stark end up at the Nights Watch
did he commit a crime or did you just
want to join the watch like Jon Snow
well it is closer to the second part
benjin was the youngest stark male of
his generation so he knew that he was
probably never going to inherit
Winterfell and just avoid problems he
joined the Nights Watch it's not unheard
of for noble-born youngest child's to
take the black that's actually the same
reason that Maester Aemon took the black
is because there were so many other
Targaryen that could have inherited the
throne that were in the line of
succession they didn't want it to turn
into another bloodbath and obviously
things were not that dire and how stark
like they didn't all hate each other
that much but the idea of honor and Duty
are really big things in the stark
family so so of course benjin would
think it'd be an honorable thing to take
the black but I don't think it was
anything like like what Sam wells Family
where samuel was pressured to take the
black next question Dean asks why did
Ned Stark never legitimize Jon Snow I'm
confused well I think you know a lot of
people ask that question you know why
didn't he tell Jon Snow who his mother
was you know why was this such a big
deal but you know why did he continue to
be a bastard the problem is is that I
think that there was just like a mutual
understanding of the people who
understood who Jon Snow's mother was is
that it would be better if no one knew
let's just assume for the sake of
argument that Jon Snow's parents are
Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna Stark think
about what that would do to the kingdom
if it was found out that there was a
surviving Targaryen male heir patro
lineages a really big thing he would
immediately have a more legitimate claim
to the throne than the Baratheon's did
and then on top of that consider how
everyone is slowly finding out that
Circe's children are not really
Baratheon
meaning that they definitely do not have
a claim to the throne so I think that
anybody who is at the Tower of joy or
found out later who Jon Snow's parents
were decided that it would be safer for
the realm and safer for Jon Snow if no
one found out so it's much safer for
everyone to believe that Jon Snow's a
bastard and he's never going to amount
to anything he's going to take the black
and people will just forget about him of
course best laid plans that's definitely
not going to end up happening everyone
will find out what happened to Jon Snow
eventually everyone will know his name
next question mr. Arya Stark guests what
are the chances that Jon Snow and Danny
get married a lot of people want to see
that happen it sounds a little bit like
fan fiction so it's kind of silly I'm
kind of hoping that it doesn't go that
route I'd much rather see one of them
sacrificed their lives and the other one
be forced to rebuild the kingdom in the
wake of the war with the White Walkers
but this is one of those situations
where I do kind of feel like the show
might give people the fan fiction that
they're clamoring for for better for
worse usually the fan theories people
come up with a way more interesting than
the reality of what ends up happening on
screen so like if you want to see Jon
Snow become the new night's king and get
married to a white Walker bride it
actually feels like it'd be more likely
that he engineers would team up and then
they would eventually have to rebuild
the kingdom together despite the fact
that Jon Snow will probably never be
able to love anyone else after egret
it'd be like one of those loveless
marriages like Robert Baratheon and
Cersei had but it just ends up being one
of those things that's like so far down
the road that I try not to focus about
it too much so so don't get bummed out
if you think the show isn't going to end
the way you want it to I mean it's it's
years away at this point next question
Aaron asks in aria 3 chapter Storm of
Swords page 249 hardcover that's very
specific thank you for the reference so
I'm just gonna I'm gonna skim through us
about a specific prophecy one on his
shoulder perched a drowned crow with
seaweed hanging from his wings so
without getting into super spoilers that
actually leads up into what's going on
with the Kingsmoot and it seems like
we'll get like a small version of that
next season the show is probably going
to end up cutting out a lot of the
Ironborn characters so I don't know how
they're going to modify their plight is
going to oversimplify the Kingsmoot so
don't expect it to go exactly like it
does in the books if you have read the
books if you haven't read the books then
don't worry but see we drown crows
swaying bridge it's all about balance
rado next question Matt asks what does
Littlefinger mean when
he tells Olenna Tyrell that he has a
gift for her so if you're talking about
during season 5 he was just talking
about providing him with the person that
could inform on Queen Cersei that of
course we know now is Lancel Lannister
now the thing is is that lancel might
not have known about Circe's children
that she had with Jamie but he
definitely knew that he slept with her
that by itself is a really big crime in
the eyes of the church anyway so that
would have been enough to get her in
really big trouble with the faith next
question lilo asks if Rob did indeed
named Jon Snow's there wouldn't little
finger in some way or another find out
well this is this is the problem with
little fingers character is that it's
hard to tell how smart he is in the
books compared to how smart he is on the
TV show because apparently he didn't
know anything about Ramsay snow being a
complete psychopath when he married
Sansa to him so if he didn't know about
Ramsey then how's he going to find out
about a mysterious letter you know I
think that he's heard things and it
sounds like he has an idea of what
happened between Rhaegar Targaryen and
Lyanna stark so that you know he does
have information that's very important
but without actually reading him talking
about it in the books or seeing him talk
about it on the show it's just complete
subtext at this point I think that he
would find out about Robb Stark
legitimizing Johnson I mean if it did
happen he would find out about it with
everyone else you know you'd probably be
just as surprised as anyone else to find
out about that but thank you so much
everyone for submitting questions big
stuff happening tonight the flash is
coming back and then arrows coming back
tomorrow easons shield is also tonight
too so I'll explain my scheduling just a
little bit but they just released the
dunk and egg book so that is what the
giveaway is for now congratulations to
the first book giveaway winner Darth
Zannah you and a copy of night of the
Seven Kingdoms I can get you the kindle
the paperback anything you want just be
sure to private message me on the back
end my channel swing at your contact
info what's gonna happen now is that
just for like the next couple weeks I'm
just going to be giving away copies of
the book that's what the giveaway will
be for so be sure to subscribe to get
everything actually uh someone actually
asked me for an ashara dayne bonus video
so I might actually do that next I don't
think that I've done a video for her
specifically yet I've done an Arthur
Dayne video so I'll put a link for that
in the description if you guys haven't
been watching the flash you need to
start now it's going to be awesome I
think it's hitting Netflix tonight too
so if you haven't seen scenes the one
you can totally catch up while you wait
for it to come you can click here to
watch all my flash trailer videos and
you can cook
here to learn all about Arthur Dayne in
the books thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I will totally
see you in like a couple hours
you